can I tell you something though I've
been dying to bring this up with you
just how your comment section which I'm
not sure if you read or not I don't I
don't read comments I read your comments
uh is the most humbling comment section
for me ever why because the first time I
did your show I was very nervous and you
were wonderful and uh you guys shot me
well you know you shot me kind of low
angle and I look good and it was a
decent set you know God was kind and all
the comments were like he's doing well
he's making us proud and then at the end
of it you came and stood next to me uh
on stage and we looked like Frodo and
gandals together
and
the entire comment section you can just
see them go this guy he's so we
just looked like a pencil and a rubber
together
it was terrible it didn't help that I
was wearing an eraser on my head too I
apologize for that
um no you were hilarious right away and
I I I would say the gift of getting to
do a late night show for all those years
was
meeting
so many people that are funny in
different ways and
um and then being able to reach out to
you and say would you come by and do the
podcast and get to see you you know is
uh it's joyous I mean that's my that's
that's a joy for me it really is very
meaningful what credit where it's do you
I I don't think anybody has championed
more different comics and started more
different careers than you have through
late night so I must give you that
credit the reason I it was your show was
the first thing I ever did in the states
I'd never done anything even my Netflix
special was shot abroad and so that was
my introduction so it really kicked
everything off that five minutes it
really was a powerful thing you are
welcome here anytime you won't be paid
that's the best part
and you'll probably have to wait in an
immigration line yes done for a very
long time
well this is a huge uh treat what do you
let me just make sure that I mention
what's coming up next just so that I I
do that well uh just Landing it's the
new special on Netflix so please watch
that and I think I'll be touring the
states March first onwards so it's a
veerdas.in is my sites v i r d a s dot i
n
I can't wait to see I have not seen the
special I can't wait to see it when's it
drop as the kids say uh it has dropped
it has dropped as the kids I don't know
what kids say kids don't say any of this
kids don't say it's just one emoji and a
frown is what kids say
um I get a lot of poop emojis uh verdas
Landing uh is out now and uh I'm a huge
fan and an admirer of your approach and
uh mad respect and thank you so much for
doing this thank you seriously